i am thrilled to be with the cast of
solar opposites which a show i love um
how are you enjoying comic con thus far
i'd say tippy tops
[Music]
tippy top for sure go ahead and say
tippy tops running around are you tip
top tippy tops yeah yeah i'm so
i have a million questions but i think i
have to start with the most important
thing do you think it's too on the nose
you're wearing the shirt oh yeah
i didn't know what to wear so i was like
i'm just going to wear wear the guy
or the sharp the short people you're
always branding sean
i'm always promoting that yeah i'm a big
fan of the show and but there's going to
be a lot of people out there watching
who've actually never seen it how do you
typically describe solar opposites to
like friends and family when they ask
you about it i say get all your young
kids
um the youngest the younger the better
have them watch it there's a lot of
violence a lot of swearing let's go and
prepare them for the real world that's
what i thought i lead with that yeah
it's definitely a kids show yeah
it's a kids it's a children's cartoon
about a family of cussers and murderers
for kids
totally for kids
you're well
[Laughter]
you're the youngest you would know
sean was two and he started this
two years old one of the things though
that i love about the show is truly
every episode can go off the rails in
any any direction you really don't know
what's gonna happen what is it like for
you guys getting the scripts are they as
chaotic as i would imagine or how much
is found when you guys are recording
we do a lot we you we give them what
don't we all give them like three
straight reads and then go off yeah and
improv i mean it's definitely i've had
my fair share of moments where i'm
reading the lines and just i have to do
another take because i laugh in the
middle of them because they're so
ridiculous like some of the
some of the especially the references
all the specific random references that
they throw in there i'm like wow well
played that came out of nowhere yeah but
yeah we'll usually get it on on book as
they say and then give a couple of goofs
as an industry standard term for going
off book is goofs
right you guys do goofs yeah i do a goof
spoof yeah
it's extra yeah i i kind of just stick
with the script i'm i might have to
throw in a couple more goofs
like future records but i can't just
because usually when i read it it's it's
something that i could not like or i've
never thought of and just cracks me up
so i usually just stick with the script
but yeah sometimes i feel a lot of shame
after i say something
do you know what i mean like did i just
say that out loud like and then i and
i'm like i'll give you a clean take like
no swears or nothing
they love it
they love the clean stuff
these guys eat the clean stuff right up
yeah they do and then i like to say amen
after a lot of the lives you do you do
and you end every session with a prayer
that's nice of you uh how often have the
three of you done voicemails and what do
i need to do to get one done
that's a great idea
maybe that'll be our cameo business yeah
yeah shawn and i were going to do those
bicycle cabs next year we're going to
start that on as our side hustle but
maybe maybe we could just do like voice
mess charge people to to do their
voicemail it's going to be a lot though
or for free yeah we do yours for free
though
[Laughter]
you just undercut my price right i'm
just i'm i'm i'm sort of joking around
but i know that a lot of uh
[Laughter]
yes
it's good that no one's wearing a mask
it's not like covers around it to the
sea
i send it to the ocean right the wind's
going this way by the way so i'm feeling
good but you two are effed
yeah i thought that was the sea mist
coming at me
not at all it's my germs uh being uh so
uh how far ahead you guys were already
renewed for season four and i know
there's a holiday special coming later
this year a halloween one how far ahead
are you guys actually in the recording
process uh
well right now we're recording
season four we haven't got to halloween
yet no i'm not sure i think we already
do this i don't know we're we're out on
drugs we have no idea no we're not but
but we are but we're not uh just
pharmaceutical yeah uh did we do that up
is that in season three no no it's
coming up it is well that you know we
got we got it takes what you what you
don't
realize with animation it takes long
time to draw all those little drawings
so you got to record them
well in advance and by the time we have
interviews like this about season three
we have to like watch it again to
remember so yeah but yeah we're i think
we're all recording season four right
now yeah in the middle of four
i believe yeah one of the story lines
which like everyone who watches the show
that i love is obviously the stuff with
the wall um when did you guys first like
sort of how did you hear about was it in
the scripts like what's been your
reaction to it because it's so ingenious
and brilliant and not what any other
show does i remember well the first
script had the wall and i was like oh
there's not much terry in this
and i just threw it away
but then when i saw it i was like oh i
see what they were doing it's very funny
and then i was mad and envious and i
came to uh the studio and wrecked
everything and said don't you ever do
this to me again i don't know what you
guys do
my read my first read and i did go up
against some of the best children in
hollywood by the way for the part
but my
read was about the wall
so i kind of had the first insight
because that was my that was my like
little test screen test was
wall content yeah i i
i was shrinking down a person
in it and i was like
i already know what's happening in the
whole season now from from i kind of
could see it from the audition and these
guys didn't have to audition
but i did
and i'd like to bring that up that i
actually earned my position
on the show
um and these guys they just aren't used
to working hard anymore i'm always
grandfathered in justin ruslan's my dad
so
it's nepotism at its finest yes
he's both he's your dad too yeah yeah
shawn and i are brothers yeah and we
can't stand each other
between us
i keep them apart i keep them separated
what's interesting about animation and i
think a lot of people realize is often
you're recording by yourself but i've
spoken to a lot of people that record
together do you guys ever actually get
to record together
we did we for the first season and then
then for like a publicity thing the
whole group did one time but never yeah
never all it at once it's not standard
on our show no it's not but but
um
you had a good point we were talking
about it and
thomas said why would somebody else want
to sit there and listen to you go
oh like different ways
to put somebody else through that like
the weird
it makes it a longer process no no
totally i get it when you're talking
about like for people that don't realize
i think that the terminology is called
like efforts yeah or something
and so i understand like obviously if
you're doing efforts
who the hell wants to be in the room but
i mean when you're doing like dialogue
scenes you know i wonder you know what i
mean yeah i think it's sometimes it goes
it just goes quicker when you have
because you know typically you get a
line and you say it at least you know
three different times and then you might
need to say it a bunch
just because especially in our show it
needs to be quicker
a lot of a lot of our lines are yelled
yes and so yeah so
and so you just get a lot of the notes
of like hey louder faster and you're
like okay and that might take you six or
seven times to get it right and you know
like yeah you just kind of want to
screw tighten the screws on that on
these i said of the lines and not have
to constantly do the back of the
teleplay
we we would all go crazy if we had to
sit there and listen to each person i
can't stand
we hate each other i think they do a
terrible job on the show these guys are
the worst yes i didn't want to say
anything
i didn't want to say anything about your
your co-stars but yeah they are pretty
bad they're pretty stinking yeah
they really are they
they bring the show down they have no
talent i don't enjoy their voices on the
show they don't make me laugh every
episode you know not not at all horribly
cast
i i completely concur
obviously i'm joking around i want to be
serious the show's fantastic you
obviously all need to watch this please
make sure you tune in hulu it's real
good uh we're at comic-con
what do you guys actually obsess over or
collect in terms of if you had the if
you go down the convention what would
you buy oh
that's so hard maybe a nice set of
polyhedrals
get my get my dice game elevated
because i do like to roll them bones
sure
uh in a fantasy setting of course
is bojack horseman here
i don't know if it's here this year but
it has been
i'd like a little bojack horseman
figurine
you could definitely get that on the
floor there's a dog in my neighborhood
named mr peanut butter
and i love mr peanut butter i walk by
his i walk by his yard all the time just
so i can yell mr peanut butter but our
show is way better than that one
yeah
good save yeah
yeah
i'd probably get some comics or
something because
yeah i don't know i i'm just some random
comic if i like the artwork or something
yeah have you guys actually been on the
convention floor before
yes
yeah we went we're there
uh in 2019 but thomas couldn't come
because he had
prior engagements
because he's also a diva you can just
say it yeah david ditch yeah
let it be known
baby
yeah
yeah i know i've been on there it's it's
it's a wild time i i've realized that
that like my relationship with comics is
like neophyte at best
and so i i would i saw i remember
santorini like i'm gonna really sink my
teeth into me like i don't know anything
about it
this is very overwhelming yeah one of
the things though that i love and um i'm
sure you guys agree is that uh what i
love about comic-con is just all the
people here are like like
fans they're legit fans like you you to
spend the money to come here to all the
effort of like you know you see how what
it's like outside it's chaos to go
through this you really want to be here
yeah this is not like uh you know oh
[ __ ] it let's just come down yeah yeah
and i think when there's like a little
bit of mutual appreciation it's very
much like one of us like it feels like
one singular
mob entity of
fandom and nerdum which is like really
sweet
it's it's nice that there's a place for
that jumping back into the show um
obviously there have been some and i
don't know if you're gonna remember
season one anymore since you're in
season four but is there a storyline
that you especially loved recording or a
memory from the recording process that
really sticks with you something like
you'll never forget i remember picking
on sean a lot during
during our um our very few uh duo
records um for season one and i cherish
the times when i've made sean feel like
[ __ ]
is it because he didn't audition
oh yeah oh yeah anytime i can take these
guys down a peg i'm in and i will
remember that straight to my deathbed i
will remember that
that that's my honest answer very
competitive mary is yes yeah i am
i auditioned for terry and yamil he's
the she's the
you're the daniel plainview of voiceover
i have a competition in me
do you have any uh any favorite story
lines though
uh i'm i'm enjoying the
sort of ambiguous progression of um
platonic romance with corvo and terry i
think that's been delightful to explore
oh yeah um
there's that escalates in season four
something to something to look forward
to
oh yeah
it's a great story i i also enjoy that
storyline yeah it's spicy yeah and and
and
i i like that um
yum yulak is listening to jesse a little
bit more
on the show they're not as
i mean they're still adversarial but
they're not killing each other as much
and that's a big step forward although
in our real-life relationship
we still
have it we still hate each other yeah
with good reason
uh on that note i'm gonna be letting you
guys go and i'm just gonna say sincerely
i really really enjoy your show and i
really do hope everyone tunes in it is
streaming on i believe it's called hulu
yes and i think it's it's a streaming
channel if you're not familiar i'm
obviously [ __ ] around everyone knows
hulu um but seriously thank you so much
for coming in and uh congrats on you
know the show being a hit thank you
thank you so much
you